[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le débat sur les
statistiques ethniques vient de se
rouvrir en france à la suite de la mort
de georges floyd et des remous que cela
provoquait chez nous certains y voient
d'excellents outils pour lutter contre
le racisme et les discriminations
d'autres y voient au contraire une
racialisation de la société une manière
de compter les gens fonction de l'orgie
origine ou de leur couleur de peau ce
qui serait incompatible avec le modèle
républicain c'est donc presque toujours
au nom de l'antiracisme que l'on est
pour ou contre les statistiques
ethniques
alors pour y voir plus clair nous avons
invité esther benbassa sénatrice europe
ecologie les verts de paris
universitaire êtes l'auteur de la
république face à ces minorités les
juifs hier les musulmans aujourd'hui ou
de la possibilité de devenir français
êtes favorable depuis de nombreuses
années aux statistiques ethniques pouvez
vous nous dire pourquoi on de mostar
benbassa si on veut mesurer l'étendue
des discriminations il faut passer par
là pour qu'on puisse aiguilles et nos
politiques publiques et lutter contre
ces discriminations c'est aussi je pense
que c'est sain c'est une volonté vouloir
les statistiques ethniques c'est une
volonté de vouloir s' est il de plus
près les mécanismes de discrimination
qui mine n'est ce pas le fondement même
de ce que nos un peu long l'égalité
républicaine
hervé lebras démocra fpt historien
chercheur émérite à l'ined l'institut
national d'études démographiques d'être
l'auteur de l'invention de la france
avec emmanuel todd et vous faisiez
partie des auteurs du retour de la race
un livre collectif contre les
statistiques ethniques paru il ya dix
ans aux éditions de l'aube
pourquoi êtes vous contre le thabor mais
j'aimerais dire vous le dire avant comme
je suis d'origine bretonne on dit le
braz est pas le bras bon vous me l'aviez
déjà dit d'ailleurs ce que j'ai
alors maintenant je ne suis pas pour
compte les statistiques ethniques c'est
comme si on demandait
etes-vous pour ou contre le climat ou la
cuisine il s'agit de savoir quel climat
quelle cuisine or si on prend la
question des statistiques ethniques qui
a d'abord deux formes de statistiques
ethniques il ya une première forme c'est
à travers des recensements aider les
actes de l'état civil c'est-à-dire tout
le monde est logé dans cette statistique
et puis il ya des études statistiques
des monographies des enquêtes et les
deux sont les procédés très différents
et puis ensuite il ya ce qu'on appelle
le référentiel c'est à dire ça peut être
soit des pays d'origine des parents des
ans par an soit une classification
ethnique je pense qu'on reviendra là
dessus et suisse pour ou contre
je suis en fait contre une seule chose
suis contre les référentiel ethno
raciaux obligatoire c'est-à-dire dans le
recensement pour les trois autres formes
j'ai aucun problème je suis d'accord
voilà ma position sur les statistiques
ethniques
alors que la première question que
j'avais envie de vous poser 2 c est ce
qu on connait vraiment notre pays si
l'on refuse de prendre en compte en fait
la france multiculturelle telle qu'elle
peut nous apparaître quand on sort dans
la rue notamment dans une grande ville
comme paris et si on préserve l'illusion
au fond du nu d'une identité nationale
en général blanche et chrétienne qui
existe pourtant de moins en moins est ce
que pour connaître ce pays ne
faudrait-il pas justement compte est
classifié tout ce que l'on se refuse à
faire en fait aujourd'hui
esther benbassa hervé le bras et star
oui je pense que on est un peu dans le
déni l'identité qu'on appelle française
et les
multiples il n'y a pas une seule
identité et nous sommes depuis un moment
dans la dans les revendications
identitaires plus plus au volant
invisible les différentes composantes de
la france de la nation plus et plus on
risque de tomber dans un identitaire
très fort ce qu'on voit dans certains
pays on voit actuellement en france on a
vu quand même et que ça traoré impute ul
des sangles vingt mille personnes
il y a quelques semaines devant le
tribunal le tgi de paris
j'ai vu là c'était pas que des gens de
couleur il y avait des jeunes plants des
jeunes noirs beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes
et récemment aussi à la république plus
de 40000 personnes à savoir que en
france on est en train d'arriver vers ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis qu'on a vu
dans les universités je n'ai vu quand
j'enseignais il ya longtemps puisque
j'étais professeur d'université et on
voit comment la politique aujourd'hui
aux états unis et surtout composée de
cette revendication identitaire et ça va
venir en france aussi faire des
statistiques ce n'est pas en soi quelque
chose de disons enfin ne doit pas rester
un tabou regarder lorsqu'on ce que
lorsqu'on a eu ce travail très
intéressant la date du nord de nos
collègues les obèses et les vies sur les
contrôles au faciès
on a pu constater que les arabes sont
son contrôle est huit fois plus qu'une
personne blanche et épauler les noirs
c'est six fois plus lorsqu'on voit ça on
comprend aussi cette colère contre les
violences
actuellement contre les violences
policières
c'est vraiment là on est en train de
tourner autour du sujet je crois qu'on
est en plus en train de se rapprocher de
dunes des enduits d'une de l'arrivage à
aux statistiques ethniques
si bête ndiaye a récemment fait allusion
enfin peut-être que on devrait le voir
ce problème différemment et voit comment
on peut faire des statistiques ethniques
sans qu'il y ait cette division dès
qu'elles craignent ceux qui sont contre
compte les statistiques ethniques
la cohésion de la nation ne sera que
l'on pensait et granulés dit ne pas
vouloir regarder ce qui se passe et
admettre que la france est
multiculturelle même si je ne parle pas
là du multiculturalisme la france est
multiculturelle voilà un vrai bras oui
alors je trouve que ce qu'un ben bassin
donné un très bon exemple du résultat
des statistiques ethniques avec les
états unis effectivement on ne peut que
souhaiter que il se passe en france qui
se passe aux etats-unis l'âge c'est
courageux de sa part de le dire
maintenant est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
statistiques et de résultats sur la
diversité de la france il ya énormément
d'encre quêtes et de travaux qui sont
très importants qui sont bien connues
qui sont ont été de assez facile à
monter d'ailleurs esther benbassa viens
de citer
l'excellent travail de fabien jobard et
rené lévy les deux qu'elle avait
d'ailleurs témoigné dans notre
commission la carsed et nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord avec ce qui peut le
travail la commission à laquelle vous
faites allusion à hervé le bras
c'est une commission justement contre
les statistiques ethniques à lennon
kendall et compte continuer celle en
quête non ou taisez moi avoir à attendre
paroles un peu près comme il y avait une
dame noire d
laissez-moi de développer mon art du
mort quand même l'enquète dont il a été
question c'est une enquête sur le
contrôle au faciès on peut revenir c'est
une excellente méthodologie c'est le
type même d'un certain nombre d' enquête
qui existent en france sur des sujets
précis ou sur des sujets généraux il
existe aussi un très grand nombre d'
enquête beaucoup plus générale notamment
sur les discriminations ça a commencé
avec une enquête qui s'appelait mg yes i
in sedin n y en a une autre qui
s'appelle t euros qui va être répétée et
puis un beau coup de travaux qui utilise
des critères alors qu'ils utilisent
parfois des critères d'origine nationale
d'autres fois il utilise des critères
qu'on appelle parfois ethno raciaux donc
là il n'y a absolument pas de problème
si on veut être enseignée sur ces choses
on les trouve le problème de qui se pose
c'est pas du tout qu'on ne soit pas
renseigné c'est le pouvoir politique ne
fait strictement rien si on l'en quête
de jobards et de lévis elle a
parfaitement montré ce qu'était des
contrôles au faciès maintenance et puis
on n'a plus besoin d'autres statistiques
sur ce sujet on peut répéter l'an
question veut elle donnera hélas sans
doute les mêmes résultats
mais maintenant si on pouvoir politique
d'agir il à agir pour que les contrôles
au faciès ne se fasse plus de cette
façon dont il se passe actuellement j'en
ai notamment quelqu'un comme patrick
jane est absolument d'accord avec moi
sur ce point c'est au gouvernement
d'agir madame benbassa est une femme
politique elle s'occupe de politique
qu'elle agisse qu'elle dépose des
projets de loi je tiens absolument pas
mon affaire
mais au lieu de fermer au lido s'y
prendre pour une scientifique non elles
agissent comme une politique elle est
comme lippi qu'elle est marqué comme
sénatrice elle agisse si vous voulez
temps est assez on en a assez de ces
matériaux qui montre bien la diversité
de la france mais problème des
discriminations
on peut continuer je voulais dit je suis
pour qu'on continue à faire des enquêtes
sur la descente est comme celle de joe
bar et lévis mais grand nombre d'
enquête a tout récemment il ya une très
bonne sur la mortalité infantile des
enfants selon le pays d'origine des
parents voilà on peut faire énormément
de choses
il ya une base de
il ya une passe d' enquête énorme qui
s'appelle l'échantillon démographique
français à nantes ou qu'elle les
chercheurs ont facilement accès on a 5 %
des actes de la population française on
peut par exemple faire des travaux il ya
bien un excellent travaux sur le chômage
dans la seconde génération le problème
c'est toutes ces choses là l on lis on
les connaît elles sont sur la place
publique simplement on fait semblant de
les ignorer ou tirait pour des lubies
comme d'aller mettre dans le recensement
des catégories ethniques on me dira
lesquels d'ailleurs plus tard une
question en plus hervé le bras juste
jouer une question de plus pour y avait
le bras et en ce qui concerne les
musulmans en france par exemple on voit
des chiffres absolument qu'ils n'ont
rien à voir les uns avec les autres
alors ils seraient entre 4 et 8 millions
mais j'ai l'impression quand on regarde
donc en fond on compte là les gens dont
les parents ou les grands-parents
étaient originaires de pays musulmans
en fait j'ai l'impression qu'on compte
des musulmans athées c'est à dire des
gens qui ne vont pas plus à la mosquée
que les enfants et les petits enfants
des catholiques ne vaut aujourd'hui à la
messe est ce qu'on sait est ce que un
démographe tels que vous c'est ou du
mois une notion de combien il y a de
musulmans en france et dieu sait si on
en parle de ça oui tout à fait c'est je
peux je peux en parler assez largement
j'ai fait un travail sur ce sur ce sujet
sur comment on pouvait compter les le
nom nous avoir une estimation du nombre
de musulmans d'abord c'est la même chose
que pour statistiques ethniques
musulmans ne signifie pas grand chose
c'est comme chrétien ça ne signifie pas
grand chose tout les sociologues des
religions savent que il faut distinguer
le type de chrétiens auxquels on a
affaire c'est à dire le non pratiquants
qui a été baptisé de non pratiquants qui
va quelquefois à la messe on l'appelle
souvent le pascaa lisant celui qui va à
la messe chaque fois chaque dimanche
qu'on appelle de messalisants donc il
faut d'abord dans le musulman c'est une
pratique ce n'est pas une origine
ethnique
et quand on fait le calcul et j'avais
fait des calculs à partir d'un certain
nombre de données
on arrive disons entre actuellement le
dossier
bien sûr forcément grossier je peux pas
entrer dans le détail des calculs mais
entre 600 mille et un million cent mille
ha ti camp musulman en français alain
bauer béquille j'en avais parlé qui à
l'époque de sarkozy s'occupaient de
cette question ministère de l'intérieur
arrivait ainsi voisins même plus faibles
et y arriver par une autre voie que moi
ma voix était statistiques et lui il est
arrivé par les contacts les comptages
des renseignements généraux dans les
mosquées dans les salles de deux buts
alors bien sûr tout ça est imprécise
mais le chiffre de 4,6 millions parfois
7 millions précédemment très serré et
recouvre il recouvre des tattes
musulmans des musulmans effectivement
dont un des grand père était peut-être
musulmans et les trois autres c'est pas
quoi breton corse mais ça n'a pas de
sens l'expo il faut entrer à nouveau
dans toutes ces questions il faut entrer
dans le détail il faut dire exactement
ce qu'on cherche à mesurer et ne pas
lancer déterrement en général comme
celui de musulmans esther benbassa oui
je voudrais d'abord réagir à ce qu'a dit
monsieur le braz et écoutez monsieur je
suis politique certainement mais j'ai
été scientifiques comme vous n'est ce
pas j'avais une shell d'histoire des
religions à la sorbonne j'ai pas besoin
de le recevoir des leçons de pau excusez
moi donc je connais cette question de
des deux côtés mais d'abord je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ce que vous dites des
musulmans c'est comme les juifs via des
juifs de culture est-ce qu'ils
pratiquent la religion que je n'en sais
rien ils vont pas tous les jours à la
synagogue alors et c'est très difficile
de faire la distinction
parce que comme vous le savez à l'époque
moderne elle les gens je revendique une
appartenance culturelle aussi on n'a pas
seulement en interne ans de pratique
alors écoutez c'est pour ça peut-être
que c'est difficile de comptabiliser
ceux qui sont combien de musulmans en
france
combien de chrétiens etc en tout cas je
voudrais aussi prendre un autre exemple
regarder pour les femmes bon tout le
monde sait que les femmes gagnent moins
que les hommes
et c est qu elles sont moins représentés
dans la politique dans les parties et
c'est le jour où on a commencé
et enfin parce que il ya eu une bataille
on s'est battu on a et il ya eu le
féminisme qui est passée par là
aujourd'hui on sait combien de femmes et
quel est le pourcentage des femmes qui
sont payés moins que les hommes
combien de femmes il y a dans les
conseillers administratifs et combien de
femmes font des études scientifiques etc
la quantification est toujours à aide
les politiques aussi à prendre des
décisions si on vous avez écouté par
exemple prenez dans le domaine des
femmes on aurait été encore on aurait
subi ce retard est aujourd'hui les
choses avancent il ya même loi sur la
parité
heureusement qu'il ya eu une loi sur la
parité n'est ce pas alors qu'il y ait
des statistiques ethniques en france et
ça aurait aidé par exemple comme en
amérique actuellement avec le co vide de
quantifier le nom de noa et qui ont
attrapé le coc vide en raison de leur
précarité que ce soit au niveau du
logement est de la santé etc
en france on ne saura jamais pourquoi
dans le 93 il y avait il y avait plus de
co vide des malades de coheed du coc
vite que dans d'autres départements
est ce que on osera dire en france que
ceux qui ont attrapé ses malaises cette
maladie c'était ces gens qui a lieu au
travail lorsque nous nous faisions du du
télétravail et que la majorité c'était
des noirs et des arabes
alors il faut quand même dire les choses
comme elles sont et pas c'est vous voyez
c'est ce côté un peu voilà quand on
saura combien d'arabe et
non non elle ne trouve pas un travail à
la hauteur de leurs diplômes et
peut-être on agira autrement aussi bien
dans l'accompagnement et scolaire
universitaire et au niveau de l'emploi
lorsqu on dira on saura combien de
personnes noah habitent les banlieues et
que lorsqu'ils envoient leur cv ils ne
sont pas leurs cv ne sont pas ne sont
même pas lus n'est ce pas on saura mieux
comment agir alors les politiques ce ne
sont pas des utopistes
ils ont besoin d'outils et les
statistiques ethniques sont des outils
des outils qui nous permettront de deux
d'endiguer les discriminations qui
permettent un certain un certain nombre
d'ailleurs un grand nombre de personnes
issues de l'immigration ayant une
couleur de peau différente de celle de
la majorité
les personnes qui sont nées en france de
la troisième génération de la deuxième
génération de la première génération
voir les évolutions peut-être elles
seront elles sont positives je n'en sais
rien
donc il ya plein de choses à faire et la
loi ne l'interdît pas ce n'est pas
illégal de faire des statistiques
ethniques vous savez qu'il ya des
délégations à l'intérieur de la loi du 6
janvier 1978 et qui autorise n'est ce
pas de faire des statistiques avec des
données subjectives et des données
objectif
alors on va on va pas entrer dans la
législation
la législation en cas de contrôle régule
les statistiques et c'est très bien
comme ça on peut aller de l'avant pour
landre plus facile aux chercheurs même
s'il ya déjà des travaux mais qui sont
utilisés que par des scientifiques
langue elle et les travaux plus facile
plus accessible que nous les politiques
nous puissions agir différemment vers le
bas oui ben bien sûr c'est tout ça c'est
des voeux pieux parce que d'accord avoir
des outils etc
moi ce que j'attends des politiques
c'est qu'ils me disent comment se servir
d'eux
ces outils c'est ça qui m'apporte alors
dans tout ce que vient de dire madame
ben henda ben oui on a appelé le brave
nous sommes trompés sur votre nom hein
qu'est ce que moi on se trompe sur le
maillage on ne passera d'errance coq en
samarie dessus polique contre pas alors
cette histoire je vais reprendre un
point est tout à fait intéressant
l'histoire du coc vide 19 qui se trouve
que j'ai pas mal travaillé sur les
données du copic 19 j'ai vu d'ailleurs
publié une note assez importante à la
fondation jean jaurès sur ce sujet il ya
d'abord il faut voir que ce que dit un
mb bassin est fou le risque de la
proportion de tuer par habitant de mort
par habitant par le coz is not jusqu'à
maintenant en seine saint denis
elle est la même c'est le département le
plus pauvre de france
et oui elle elle est la même mais bête
vous détestez vous laissez le parler moi
je vous ai laissées par les débiter des
bêtises
laissez moi parler donc là cette
proportion est la même elle peut le
vérifier on peut le vérifier sur ton on
ait pu france peut dans la département
voisin et autres chaînes qui est le plus
riche de france
donc il faut être très attentif quand on
regarde ces chiffres et quand on parle
de ces choses là
en plus de ce temps c'est pas du tout
les noirs ne sont pas plus attaquées par
le logobi 10 avril c'est parce que c'est
un noir le comique 19 qui n'est pas
capable de savoir ce qu'est un noir et
un pauvre externe ce qu'il est capable
de voir celle et d'attaquer c'est les
gens qui sont proches de l'unité et le
problème bucovine 19 dans tous les pays
d'ailleurs c'est le problème des gens
qui sont exposés opposite 19 c'est donc
le problème des personnes qui
travaillent dans le secteur sanitaire et
médecins les infirmières le personnel
sanitaire le problème aussi des
personnes qui travaillent dans la
distribution dans l'alimentation dans
les services nécessaires
il se trouve que parmi ces personnes il
ya une plus forte proportion parce que
c'est souvent des métiers difficiles ou
même justement à risque et une plus
forte proportion d'antillais en france
notamment
en allemagne une plus forte proportion
de notamment d'indiens donc c'est ça qui
essaient c'est pour cela que ces
personnes là sont plus touchés c'est pas
parce qu'elles sont noirs le cofidis en
fout du la couleur de peau parce
qu'elles sont bois tel ou tel ou telle
couleur c'est parce qu'elles sont dans
des métiers d'ailleurs dont souvent on
peut souvent les français
particulièrement dans la prison
parisienne ne veulent pas de me répondre
donc ça ne sert à rien je dirais de
mesurer le nombre de noirs ou de weeds
arabe puisque vous parlez d'un ver à se
presser qu'un arabe bientôt ça ne sert à
rien d'aller mesurer cela ce qui sert à
quelque chose c'est de mesurer quelles
sont les personnes atteintes dans les
professions à risque et ça je les
demande et notamment
je voudrais savoir depuis je demande
depuis longtemps et les la proportion de
personnels de santé des infirmières et
médecins qui ont été frappés et qui sont
morts par le codi docteur seulement ne
veut pas donner cette proportion on l'a
en italie elle est très importante et
donc odeur suspecte qu'en france aussi
elle est non négligeable
c'est ça faire du travail et c'est pas
aller prendre une variable qui est une
variable on appelle proxy qui n'est pas
la vraie pause des choses à vraie cause
des choses c'est la proximité de la
maladie quant aux yeux et aux questions
de à la question de l'espace disponible
de du confinement des petits logements
j'ai publié un article dans la revue de
fottorino le 01 j'ai calculé par la cua
vous suit peuvent servir des
statistiques est calculée quel était le
nombre moyen de pièces disponibles en
différentes conditions notamment par
exemple quand on est ouvrier ou quand on
est cadre vous allez être assez étonné
nombre de pièces disponibles par ouvrier
et par cadre est à ses voisins il n'y a
pas une grosse différence il n'y a pas
une grosse différence parce que les
ouvriers habitent en dehors des villes
ou en proximité des villes dans des
pavillons qui ont un départ plus est ce
parce que les appartements à l'intérieur
des villes donc c'est des choses comme
ça qu'il faut regarder il faut être ici
et moi par exemple quand sa vie arabe
blanc
juif pour moi c'est extrêmement vague
alors est ce qu'elle compte faire des
statistiques ethniques c'est ma question
dans lesquels dans la liste des
statistiques technique qui aura marqué
etes-vous juifs ou non et vous arabe ou
non voilà moi j'aimerais bien savoir
j'aimerais bien savoir quel est son
référentiel puisqu'elle veut des
statistiques générales et michael
catégorie elle va utiliser qu'elle me
dise un peu les catégories telles va
utiliser nos vies personnelles ont fait
une pause dans une minute trente mais
allez-y
je voudrais l'appareil après on va
écouter je veux donner les chiffres
parce que vraiment il ya des chiffres
pour ce le département de saint denis le
la surmortalité a bondi de près de 50 %
entre le 1er mars et le 27 avril par
rapport à la même période jouée au sénat
voilà mais alors bon non c'est pas les
mêmes chiffres
monsieur vraiment là vous voulez magie
l'arrêt en connaissez vous décidez vous
pourrez laisser ses virées sépare coded
voilà locaux vince ne connaît pas le
noir l'autre etc
néanmoins ce sont les catégories les
plus précaires et les noix et les
personnes issues de l'immigration et
longeant des descendants sont les
personnes sont les personnes qui faisait
des travaux les plus les plus exposés
ddd pinsolle enfin le personnel
hospitalier dans les étables et ses
rangs les femmes de ménage on va c'est
lié à la précarité
j'espère les noix les maires solution de
modération se disant plus sûres qui ont
été bien sûr mais au bout d'un effort
monsieur mes autres d'où cette
surmortalité dans le département de
saint-louis parce que la souhaite
scientifique je voulais faire même si
vous voulez
ce sont les chiffres officiels je les ai
devant moi je vous interromps je vous
interromps fait une pause et on revient
tout de suite après ça fait plus d'une
vingtaine d'années qu'un certain nombre
d'événements inattendus qui bouleverse
est fort dans mondial on essaie le faire
perdurer mais on est à la fin d'un
modèle qui était le tout misé sur la
dette
tu es la tête et la relance par la dette
ou par la création monétaire
c'est quelque chose qui a fonctionné
systématiquement on l'a dit des milliers
de fois c'est pas en imprimant des
billets que vous relancer une économie
si on essaie autant de relancer la
croissance économique s'est peu
fondamentalement on sait on sait pas
faire sans pas censés connaître
je peux pas continuer à diffuser des
chiffres qui sont absolument faux
simplement parce que ça arrange monsieur
trump à ce moment là
[Musique]
je me suis dit mais c'est pas possible
c'est rien plus rien pendant le temps on
voudra nous enfermer tout seul dans ses
cuisines et bains je me suis aperçu que
c'était bien plus difficile qu'avec une
équipe de 25 l'usiné autour pour nous
pour nos fournisseurs pour nos équipes
c'était essentiel de rire le plus tôt
possible
beaucoup des mises de la vie ne
reprendra pas de la même façon je
n'adhère pas à cette théorie du monde
d'avant du monde d'après je crois que le
groupe d'avants il était formidable et
qu'on a envie de le retrouver je pensais
que ça allait me rendre plus tolérante
et ça m'a rendu plus intolérant alors
par se briser justement délirer autour
d'un dessert que j'ai appelé la pêche la
patate
je voulais vraiment montrer que le monde
d'après il serait aussi dynamique et
tonique le monde d'avant
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur les statistiques
ethniques avec esther benbassa qui est
sénatrice europe ecologie les verts de
paris avec hervé le braz qui est
démographe et historien
on voit bien que sur ce sujet certains
se disent que c'est quand même bizarre
que pour intégrer les gens il file est
classé dans des communautés on se dit ça
peut c'est plutôt contradictoire en même
temps on leur répond que refusé de
nommer les groupes au sein de la
communauté
c'est pas pour autant que ces groupes
n'existent pas alors vous l'avez dit
avait le bras comment procéder au fond
ce serait ça si on devait
faire des statistiques ethniques le
problème ce serait de classer les gens
en fonction de quoi
esther benbassa voudriez les voudriez
que ce soit déclaratif est pas
obligatoire il n'ya pas obligatoire ça
existe déjà en espagne les données
objectives comme le nom l'origine
géographique la nationalité antérieure à
la nationalité française s'est autorisée
n'est ce pas
la loi autorise aussi le traitement des
données est subjective moi je le
ressenti le ressenti d'appartenance
il faut voir ces genres la démographie
est une science en guillemets mais en
même temps ne prend pas en considération
le ressenti des gens alors aujourd'hui
appartenir à des groupes minoritaires
ont dit qu'is mais aussi les
minoritaires parce que oui ils sont
minoritaires par rapport à la majorité
mais les minoritaires ils ont un
ressenti de nom l'intégration de non
appartenance à la nation et c'est très
important ce ressenti les gens ne sont
pas dans la rue parce que parce que tout
va bien on ne descend pas dans la rue
quand il n'y a pas cette colère de ceux
considérés comme les ans les les enfants
adoptifs de la nation et ce sont
pourtant les forces vives de la nation
et nous devrions avancer sur ces
questions si nous voulons arriver un
jour à la cohésion de la nation parce
que en même temps et on évite tous ces
mots oui mais oui en démographie à
annaba musulmans juifs etc se sont pas
dits catégories à ces scientifiques
sauf que les gens se sentent arabes
noirs juifs etc
je ne peux rien c'est pas moi qui ai
inventé ces catégories les gens on tombe
ressenti et devant devant là disons le
traitement qu'ils subissent on sait bien
qu'il ya un échec scolaire plus élevé
chez les personnes issues des minorités
que ces gens tous plus difficilement du
travail etc dans le logement
on va pas faire toutes les catégories et
dans lesquels elles sont discriminés
d'ailleurs je vous je vous convie à lire
le rapport qui viennent de sortir cette
semaine de monsieur toubon sur les
discriminations monsieur toubon n'est
pas un homme d'extrême gauche pardon
mais qui a qui a beaucoup investi sur
cette question et monsieur le braz ça
vous ont pas importera quelques éléments
pour être un peu plus souple dans votre
vision de ce qui se passe à ce niveau
puisque vous êtes content et satisfait
getty vous savez moi je n'ai aucun
intérêt à tirer de ça moi j'ai pas un
rapport en 2014
voilà c'est nous avons constaté les
mêmes choses avec autant de l'acuité sur
les discriminations et le rapport de
monsieur toubon vient confirmer
six ans après est la même chose alors
écoutez il faut qu'on agisse
le problème c'est pas d'un message
statistiques ethniques ou statistiques
pas ethnique
on peut faire des recensements aussi
comme dans certains pays où existent les
statistiques ethniques qui sont
introduites déjà dans le recensement bon
écoutez il ya des moyens
il n'y a pas que le travail des
scientifiques parce que le travail des
scientifiques laissent dans des cercles
fermés et ne permet pas de régler la
question et de l'universalité de la
france je veux bien croire mais
l'universalisme français pour le moment
reste blanc masculin et catholique
bon voilà c'est pas moi qui ai inventé
cette définition de l'universalité
il ya eu pas mal de travaux en langue à
anglo saxon sur ces questions donc
maintenant ne chipotons passionnément
il faut aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est
d'améliorer la condition de ces
personnes parce que là il ya une grande
colère et c'est le moment
ah y'a aucun syndicat qui peut faire
descendre dans la rue
quarante cinq mille personnes et ans
avec les raisons le 1er mai vous voyez
pas 20 à 25 personnes
alors c'est qu'il ya une colère il faut
entendre cette colère et trouver des
solutions rappeler les choses comme vous
voulez mais c'est si ça ne serait pas
avec maman des montagnes et quand même
immeuble
mais il y à eut réalisé monsieur alors
moi je me présente à vous et quand même
maintenant que maintenant je vous ai
laissé au moins 10 minutes la fin donc
alors reprenons ont déjà posé une
question madame benbassa quelle
catégorie non vous a posé une question
bien sûr est parlé pendant 10 minutes
sans répondre à cette question parce que
vous ne savez pas répondre à cette
question quelle catégorie vous allez
vous prendre pour les inscrire dans le
recensement ou dit arabe juif vous allez
mettre les juifs par exemple j'aimerais
bien avoir votre avis là-dessus
j'attends que parce que c'est ça la
vraie chose c'est de savoir quelle
catégorie on met ce qui s'appelle un
référentiel et c'est pas du tout évident
pour moyen essentiel bombardé laissez
moi parler enfin j'ai laissé parler
taisez vous allez autant que vous
n'étiez pas bloquer la conversation des
choses n'ont rien à voir avec la
question et en donnant des conseils de
démographie quand même plus assez grand
pour savoir et la démographie donc
laissez moi parler vous écouterai vous
m'écoutez vous écoute et ma question
d'ailleurs la première chose que
j'aimerais savoir dès qu'on prendrait la
parole c'est les catégories vous allez
adopter pour les mettre dans le
recensement la manière américaine je
peux vous raconter et faire un livre
avec d'ailleurs michel wievorka avec des
entrepôts log et tous les deux montré
peut-être à l'écran récemment des issues
d'une en bois mal ça s'appelle
je vais vous le dire ça s'appelle
diviser pour unir ces publiés par la
maison des sciences de l'homme
c'est un livre dans lequel nous avons
travaillé organiser des réunions à
l'université de columbia
l'institut de l'anthropologie
l'ethnologie de moscou à l'institut
d'anthropologie de brasilia et en france
entre des partisans et des adversaires
des statistiques ethniques et ce livre
tente justement d'arriver à une opinion
modéré il ne parle pas du tout de choses
comment parle madame benbassa c'est un
livre où on regarde des choses
précisément quel quelles sont les
critiques qui sont faites par exemple
aux statistiques ethniques aux états
unis quels sont ceux qui sont courts qui
sont contre la personne qui dirigeait la
délégation américaine à columbia quand
on s'est rencontrés s'appelle kenneth
prewitt et l'esprit oui tu as été le
directeur du bureau 5 suspendant 8 ans
et l'insee américain et l'esprit 8 bien
qu'ils souhaitaient et était directeur
du bureau of sound sus et contre le
stage de statistiques est non raciale il
veut retourner il a commencé à le faire
d'ailleurs dans le recensement américain
perd des statistiques et payer d'origine
et non pas raspaud là une proposition il
s'explique très bien sur ce point on a
regardé aussi les questions soulevées
par les questions de statistiques des
nationalités en russie au facebook
je vous épargne madame débat ça aurait
intérêt à lire ce livre parce qu'elle
verrait ce que c'est que de faire un
travail précis et notamment de voir ce
qui se passe dans trois pays au moins
hors de la france qui utilisent assez
massivement les statistiques ethniques
ya du bien et il ya du mal mais c'est de
ça qu'il faut discuter c'est pas faire
des grands discours sur ça va tout
changer et ça va permettre et c'est
s'est par contre universalis moi j'ai
jamais prononcé le mot d'universalisme
c'est pas ma question c'est d'aimer
questions sont relativement et même très
concrètes et une de mes questions
importantes
c'était la question de la mixité parce
que l'idée de statistiques ethniques
s'éviter que ben voilà on a une seule
origine
on est juif et on est arabe et non
surtout en france la mixité est très
développé une très grande partie des
notamment des ennemis
réponse si vous prenez le recensement
voilà une bonne façon de faire la
statistique
vous apercevrez que dans la génération
des 20 30 ans est de la moitié des
personnes qui vivent en couple vivant en
couple mixte à moitié des immigrés les
générations plus anciennes c'est témoins
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils vont déclarer
quand ils sont dans un couple où il ya
un membre du couple qui est originaire
d'algérie et puis un autre membre du
couple qui est originaire a pas de sas
ou bien de du nord de la france voilà la
question et ensuite de génération une
génération après ça va encore à se
compliquer la question de la mixité des
origines une question essentielle alors
par exemple le recensement américain
il a répondu en permettant de cocher
plusieurs cases ont fait une une
solution il s'avère que le traitement de
cette solution
en fait dans a tué la statistique
ethnique parce qu'il ya trop de
combinaisons bossi donc on revient à les
mettre ensemble et ainsi de suite
bon leur semble tout doucement brésilien
a introduit une catégorie pardo ce qui
est métisse mais qu'est ce que c'est
qu'un qu'un métis est très compliqué il
ya toutes sortes de de métis une gamme
continuent à être bonnes anthropologue
français jean louis bonniol qui
travaillent dans les antilles à recenser
tous les termes plaisant qui les
utilisent pour décrire la couleur de
peau on en a compté 27
alors est ce qu'on va mettre ses 27
terme puisque c'est ça le ressenti de
ressenti si vous voulez c'est très beau
de ressenti mais le ressenti il est
extraordinairement divers donc ensuite
une fois que chacun a mis son ressenti
il estime que cette couleur de peau et
orange marron c'est un call par exemple
aux antilles dockès qui aura une case
orange marron moi c'est des choses comme
ça si vous voulez que je veux connaître
c'est pas des grands discours sur
l'universalisme ou des choses comme ça
c'est ce que je veux comprendre c'est
concrètement quels sont les outils qui
seront utilisés une fois qu'on aura ses
soi-disant statistiques et surtout elle
est la classification qu'on veut retenir
quels sont les termes que le son de
cette classification
c'est ça qui m'importe le star benbassa
après ce cours ex cathedra enfin moi
j'ai pas été invité ici pour parler
vous parlez des notions universitaire de
la question je suis là en tant que
politique aujourd'hui et je voudrais
comprendre pourquoi vous vous opposez
temps aux statistiques et les
statistiques de chevet se faire dès que
je me les statistiques ethniques
1 les catégories peuvent être définies
par exemple je sais pas où en angleterre
et en pays de galles une question sur
l'appartenance ethnique est imposé lors
des recensements depuis 1991 y a des on
n'a pas besoin de jj barrea mais tu sais
il vaut mieux laisser vinyle un peu non
mais vous arrêtez un peu un bon jetons
alors oui mais oui oui mais les femmes
parlent aussi vous voyez autant que les
hommes c'est autorisé maintenant oui oui
vous qui l'avez les problèmes avec ça
j'ai compris r on écoute et on peut
choisir les catégories enfin qu'est ce
que ça change
si on met une question sur sur
l'appartenance ethnique dans un
recensement on n'a pas besoin de dire
juif arabe et cetera alors écoutez c'est
pas le orange marron qui nous intéresse
c'est pas le problème le plus grave en
france
si les gens sont se considèrent orange
marron ou marron orange je ne sais pas
au canada
de même la même temps après à peu près
en en 1991 si ma mémoire est bonne cette
question est posée est posée dans les
recensements de quoi avez vous peur
pourquoi vous ne voulez pas qu'on sache
qu'on sache les personnes qui composent
la nation
je vais vous citer puisqu'on est là dans
n'est ce pas dans les grandes citations
universités je vais vous citer charles
taylor
vous connaissez bien n'est ce pas qui
est un grand savant canadiens dans les
politiques of recognition il 17 est très
belle phrase les statistiques ethniques
et pourrait justement donner de la
visibilité aux minorités et permettent
la reconnaissance de leurs
particularités et donc célébrer leur
diversité
où est le mal où est le mal
voilà des poses la narration j'étais
joueur je les touche
mais j'ai toujours pas la liste des
catégories c'est ça il faut discuter
précisément sur mobile ou universitaire
vous êtes pas capables des pires que
dans la liste vous allez me juge a par
exemple dû pleuvoir esther benbassa
est-ce que rennes grégory il y ait
d'autres sont ils m'ont dit que beaucoup
de gens 78 mais si lloris n'est pas moi
je suis et j'ai goûté à six km 5 au 12
rue de varenne catégorie moi je serai un
peu plus méchant
vous pouvez trouver des catégories je
vous ai déjà cité laquelle 1911 et après
on passe quand on vous entend que comme
vous parlez là sur lot des pays
d'origine elle ce que je vous propose
une autre une autre question a bien
compris ce qui vous différencie sur ce
point avait le bras ce vous avez dit que
les statistiques sont une une excuse
pour ne pas s'attaquer uni inégalités
sociales qu'est-ce que vous entendiez
par là non je ne crois pas exactement
s'il faut mettre ça dans le contexte
parce que il faut savoir à nouveau ce
que j'ai dit d'ailleurs d'entrée de jeu
parce que c'est toujours le le problème
c'est de quoi on discute il se trouve
que hier j'ai une assez longue
discussion avec six bêtes n'diaye ce
qu'ils sont très intéressantes et
pendant font toute une partie de la
discussion on n'était pas d'accord
et puis tout d'un coup on est on l'a dit
mais qu'est ce
vous entendez c'est elle d'ailleurs ses
venues d'elles qu'est ce que vous
entendez par statistiques ethniques
donc moi je expliquer c'est ce qu'on
appelle de l'ethno raciale c'est du
ressenti d'appartenance comme le site
madame benbassa un média mais moi je
pensais plutôt au pays d'origine
alors je lui dis mais dans ce cas là
nous sommes entièrement d'accord ça pose
pas de problème le pays de naissance
vous avez je crois même sur votre
passeport
vous avez votre lieu de naissance donc
là y'a pas de problème donc cibler des
ti faut d'abord savoir de quoi on parle
et quand ici en ce qui concerne cette
question des statistiques ethniques
si ça recouvre à la fois le pays
d'origine la religion la vente en temps
des musulmans la race non on va nulle
part
donc il faut prendre une décision
là-dessus c'est pour ça que la
discussion ne peut avancer que si on dit
de quel type
on veut moi je vous donne mon
référentiel il est très simple c'est le
pays d'origine et avec ce référentiel en
fait déjà énormément de choses quand
vous avez comme pays d'origine marque et
on république démocratique du congo
vous dites vous doutez bien que c'est un
référentiel qui parlent assez simplement
et c'est un référentiel qui ne pose pas
de problèmes avec la loi et comme je
voulais dit vous avez cité charles
taylor c'est un philosophe moi je vous
ai cité un directeur et un esprit qui
d'ailleurs écrit un livre harvard
university press qui s'appelle le titre
say what is your s où il explique
justement qu'il faut aux états unis
qu'on remplace cette histoire de race
qui est fait bizarroïde d'ailleurs qu'un
nouveau un résidu du passé par des
origines il est arrivé par exemple dans
hispanique sépara c'est la question
ethnique
il a obtenu que on indique le pays
d'origine et il veut progresser dit que
ça sera très lent mais il peut
progresser dans cette voie là ma
position et les 5 verset et donc quand
on a une position autre on me dise
qu'elle est exactement le référentiel
parce que c'est là que ça devient
compliqué vous donner l'exemple en
russie on demande à une déclaration la
personne écrit son ressenti
d'appartenance dans l'article qui est
fait par une
grande offre call au brusc et une vice
directrice de l'institut d'anthropologie
et les verts filipova elle montre qu' il
ya 3500 termes différents qui ont été
données a été extrait par les russes
pour pour répondre à cette question le
problème ça a été de passer ses 3500
terme d'en faire des groupes
progressivement alors c'est chiffre
exact mais je crois qu'on est arrivé ils
sont arrivés à 192 groupe
et encore il ya des tas de contestation
elle donne des exemples parce que est
très compliqué de mettre ces choses là
ensemble voilà mais au moins je sais à
quoi j'ai à faire comme référentiel et
on a la liste des groupes le des 192
nationalité russe
c'est là qu'on peut discuter c'est quand
on sait qu'elle est le référentiel c'est
est cité référentiel du brésil dont on
peut le critiquer une fois qu'on a ce
spot ce référentiel parce que la
question de la mixité est une question
absolument essentiel si on entre dans
notre les questions être nos ethno
racial c'est pour ça que moi mourir à
l'ancienne je vous le dis il est très
simple tout le monde ya accès il pose
pas de gros problèmes légaux il ya des
très bons travaux sur ce sujet et il et
il a assez peu d'ambiguïté on me dira
bien sûr et quelques expatriés qui ont
et un enfant adam république
démocratique du congo n'ont pas c'est
pas ça qui va fausser la statistique
oui mais sur les allées par exemple s'il
est natif d'algérie qui ont plus de 60
ans on ne sait pas on n'en sait pas
beaucoup plus parce que l'algérie il ya
plus de 60 ans l'algérie étant française
ça on peut être qualifiée d' européen
d'algériens de juifs
de pieds noirs etc etc vous avez raison
vous avez raison dont on veut les mettre
tous en cela vous êtes vous voulez
qu'ils soient séparés vous voulez
partager un très grand bain très bon
pour le collaborateur et ami qui est un
auteur d'une histoire statistiques de
l'algérie km kateb
il a absolument horreur d'être
considérés comme musulmans il était
membre du parti communiste de l'homme
algérien
c'est pas des musulmans je peux je vous
le dis donc là il faut bien voir que une
carte spéciale quant à la fois parmi
tous les algériens
il y aura les rapatrier et il y aura les
huit d'algérie aura pu y aura les des
anciens du parti communiste autonomes
algériens pourquoi pas on peut le faire
puis les marocains à leur tour
demanderont peut aussi un certain nombre
d'items donc on arrivera où 192 items
des russes qui sera en face débrouiller
avec nous ça voilà pour ça que c'est que
ces points sont vraiment absolument
essentiel et en plus de cela elle assure
aussi je suis tout et esther benbassa
vous avez la parole
excusez moi est ce que je voulais
absolument oui parce que sinon une autre
fois en 8 et monsieur le brasse tout
seul comme ça ça cela plus intéressant
bon ok je me suis levé le bras spam des
catégories des référentiels les
référentiels sont indiqués par la loi de
78 de spa de 1978 et il y a les données
objectives je l' ai déjà dit plusieurs
fois mais vous me demandez toujours les
référentiels d'une origine
alors écoutez le lot l'origine
géographique la nationalité antérieure à
la nationalité française est aussi et
données subjectives comme le ressenti
d'appartenance
si en france on appliquait déjà ces
dérogations de la loi est confuse et des
travaux qui vont au delà des travaux
universitaires
si on faisait des passes qu'actuellement
tout cela est utilisé par les
scientifiques c'est une excellente chose
mais si on utilisait
c est ce qu appelle monsieur le braz
référentiel on connaître et mieux ce qui
se passe dans notre pays et ont combattu
est beaucoup mieux les discriminations
ça existe déjà dans la loi vous ne
voulez même pas accepter que la loi est
autonome et non le poteau le camp vous
dites des mentions sur ce que je dis
l'annoncé publiée vous êtes comme
monsieur trompe pas la libye non
messieurs tu as dit je peux finir le
mois mais va en effet bien il vous reste
trois minutes
oui parce que c'est quand même un peu
quand les personnes ne sont pas d'accord
l e elle vous dénigrent alors je trouve
que ce n'est pas une façon 2-2 discuter
de débattre
surtout que vous êtes un homme libéral
et vous laisser tout le monde parlait et
s'exprimer sans dénigrer qui que ce soit
et je vous rends hommage c'est que pour
ça que ce soit je suis venu réalité
alors il y à une vérité alors il faut la
la comprendre pour trouver des solutions
alors si on dit basso et valenciennes
mais pas bon il ya 128 nationalité et je
le faisais pas qu'on vienne mais c'est
pas ça le problème
on veut nous les politiques aider les
gens à sortir deux de ces problèmes qui
les accable au quotidien et qui les
empêchent de s'intégrer voilà si on veut
une intégration heureuse
il faut aller dans ce sens et je suis
convaincu même si je suis bas et ma
chronique après s'il est élu monsieur
macron réélu probablement il entend que
libérale à l'américaine
il va probablement opter pour les
statistiques ethniques et les
référentiels seront fixées par ceux dont
c'est le métier c'est tout c'est ne pas
à nous les politiques de vous dire
comment faire mais il faut faire des
travaux
quand même beaucoup plus concret et pas
des travaux du scientifique c'est votre
cette scientifique fait des travaux
scientifiques vous et pour faire avancer
la recherche mais là nous on est en
train de chercher des moyens voilà et l
monsieur toubon va dans ce sens aussi et
je vous dis je vous prierais monsieur
lebrasse de lire ce rapport nous l'avons
eu a détenu le seul être vous avez vous
lu je sais mais c'est très bien bien je
suis là c'est que j'avais à dire moi
j'essaie de dire non je m'appelle le
déni français voilà c'est le déni
français mais alors dernier mot et hervé
le braz puisque vous vous voulez aussi
une intégration heureuse je pense que
vous n'êtes pas en désaccord sur ce plan
vous pensez simplement que les
statistiques ethniques ne sont pas bons
moyens qu'on peut s'en passer
je pense que les statistiques
ethno-raciales mise dans un recensement
c'est à dire l'obligation dans le
recensement de cocher une case
ethno-raciales même un ressenti
d'appartenance parce qu'il faudra
regrouper s'est ressenti d'appartenance
je suis absolument content
en revanche il existe un très grand
nombre de moyens et d'autres moyens et
d'autres part j'ai ressenti
d'appartenance et des choses qui sont
dans un grand nombre d' enquête alors
l'âme benbassa 10 et scientifique c'est
pas lui est ou non si des enquêtes de
notamment qui sont faites partie de ces
donc ces lignes c'est aussi celle et les
recensements c'est pas du du
scientifique c'est le mot enquête et est
tout à fait là pour pour le dire
et si j'ai insisté sur le référentiel
c'est pas leurs référentiels en tant que
référentiel c'est le contenu du
référentiel des catégories à l'intérieur
du référentiel parce qu'il se trouve que
dans les enquêtes successives faites en
france a beaucoup varié et c'est fort
c'est que savary j'entendais dire à
propos de l'algérie arabe musulman mais
les algériens par exemple sont blancs
dans le recensement dans les catégories
anglaise ils sont ils font partie des
blancs alors ceci que actuellement le
président entrant voudrait introduire de
nouvelles catégories pour qu'on puisse
distinguer les arabes et iraniens dans
le recensement j'espère qu'il n'aura pas
gain de cause mais on voit bien
d'ailleurs c'est pas étonnant qu'ils se
demandent des choses de ce genre là on
voit très bien dans quelle direction
c'est ici peuvent être
utiliser c'est aussi pour ça que
j'aurais aimé que madame même samedi si
parmi toutes les catégories arabe
si elle met juive si elle mais voilà
parce que si puisqu'à ce ressenti
d'appartenance juifs dont elle a parlé
est-ce que l'on le mec comme items dans
le référentiel en question c'est
vraiment une question importante à
laquelle il faut répondre à la question
a été posée aux états unis et les
communautés juives américaines gagnent à
diverses ont reçu ces et je trouve
qu'elles ont ils raison on veut on
arrête là ce débat je vous remercie tous
les deux d'y avoir participé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
c'est un débat qui reviendra sans aucun
doute comme l'a dit esther benbassa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]